hello welcome to this video playing snow
kit and this is not he's not from
Azerbaijan but let's see there's no name
right no but he is currently in Baku I
guess he always had a different flag
within the China or something and anyway
he's in Baku for the loop yet ok after
think about this for more d5 now he had
takes right moon then I'm dropping back
Bishop age three there is some queen bee
three so here I think not completely
sure about the move water Quincy 20
Bishop g2 but ok let's go Quincy to
if following on along the lines of a
game ireland aren't atoms why can I not
take on e4 in this position does he have
some something great down
should you Ford and I'm I don't quite
don't quite see it so I'm grabbing this
so we just claims he as compensation
okay there was no direct direct argument
against it yeah it's possible that he
has compensation it's not totally
totally out of the picture so Knight
comes to before I guess I go a 395
that's a little bit under a little bit
weaken into my position also the Queen
position here feels irritating but not
much I can do about it not before yeah
it's a little bit irritating
I was thinking it if i can go Eve form
yeah this is an interesting move of
course they don't need someone a little
bit late
two beef be to this a foursome let's go
here maybe yes Queen to know what Queen
sure if five or something like that mean
okay I'm not very happy with my king one
do you want that's not my kind of chess
but it's some weapons wow that's a cool
piece of calculation if it works but
okay I have to take it so what's the
deal here
honestly I don't think it works I don't
think it works what's the thing yes one
check yet it is just one check can you
too and I'm safe what's the thing here
okay check
so it's organizing good but I'm
threatening Queen g5 within a deck yeah
okay I can take on f6 maybe this is just
a draw could be and could be that this
is just a draw unfortunately if i take
that but what is he threatening here
brooke a 3 maybe or something like that
I have g45 as an attack yeah maybe maybe
I can also go for here what's then be 54
what and the biggest issue is my one
minute clock time time morning
um bloody time
19 seconds check check check
yeah 10 seconds and Jessa it's a tool
shine win but check I'm not going to
major mr. thing I'm not going to meet
him we win this challenge I'm check
check check check check white for Fitz
Valentine yeah I know it's very easy but
I burnt lots of time unnecessarily yeah
I think this is neck and the sports egg
is probably not correct but for blitz
chess purposes is probably a kind of
okay but the peace sacrifice is just
completely incorrect the safe was just
just a big blunder I could I can still
have two minutes yeah that should be so
quite a comfortable win it's a bit of a
shame man because it says this is
actually a real joke the sacrifice but
okay gap before I had why do I take 30
seconds in yeah okay I considered the
capture but this is just going to be a
draw if at bastyr he also has luke evade
and I wasn't quite sure like a 4g form
this is the thing I sometimes hesitate
too long every move wins in this
position g44 they all win because as I
said it's just completely nothing and I
should just play move quickly than this
I'm not very practical very often in
that regard the way it was um yeah just
wise don't have to analyze anything you
it should check check the complete
destruction mmm yeah I can shine quicker
was maybe but check check or like plus a
million yeah
the whole opening i think is interesting
by the way with 93 i think that this is
an interesting kind of position I don't
like black here to be honest but people
keep playing into it and i think it's
it's fairly nice queen g6e is some what
you probably should do and now i cancel
or be three or before those moves make
quite some sense queen bee three is also
interesting voyage going into this kind
of situation where he cannot cancel
anymore it's all very very interesting
play okay well thanks for watching